[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres par la guigal anti président du
club de football de billancourt nous
ferons un point sur l'année 2016 2017
qui s'achève et surtout l'avenir du club
et puis la 19e édition du festival
solidays sera organisé du 23 au 25 juin
comme chaque année plus de 80 concerts
seront organisés sur l'hippodrome de
longchamp à l'occasion d'une conférence
de presse organisée d'assaut la semaine
dernière nous avons interviewé mc solaar
noms des parrains du festival
nous recevons tout de suite dit galanti
président du club de football de
guyancourt pour faire un point sur
l'année 2016 2017 qui s'achève
bonsoir bonsoir alors quels sont les
points forts et les points faibles de
cette année les pauvres alors une saison
sportive c'est un long fleuve tranquille
dont tous dans lequel tout est prévu
heureusement une saison il ya des
satisfactions des doutes des échecs est
donc joint c'est toujours l'heure du
bilan
exactement donc voilà alors pour pour
parler du club en général je viens c'est
franchement une belle saison on a une
équipe u15 qui depuis deux ans courait
après deux montées c'est fait on est en
ligue
donc on est très heureux on a des
féminines qu'on fait la finale de la
coupe des yvelines le fera mais bon
elles ont perdu mais contre une équipe
qui était d'intégrer mon fils est en
finale et avec un 3 4 divisions en
dessous donc on est très satisfaits de
leur parcours et dimanche on a deux
catégories u15 u17 qui font la finale la
coupe d une île à croissy sur seine
on a failli d'ailleurs faire
le jackpot parce que le u 19 et nos
seniors ont failli se qualifier pour la
finale
mais c'était pour l'année prochaine et
les points faibles
alors les points faibles bon on a on a
eu en début de saison
on y reviendra pour les seniors on a eu
des problèmes d'encadrement notamment
l'équipe 2 un départ catastrophique et
pour la une et pour la 2 au niveau des
entraîneurs au niveau des jeux vous les
joueurs la mise en place etc et on avait
choisi un coach pour l'équipe 2 bon on
va faire une affaire qui n'a pas fait la
faire et on a repris en interne un duo
qui fonctionne très bien et je dirais
même le trio fonctionne très bien parce
que l'entraîneur de l'équipe une qui est
jules morose
hélas depuis assisté de 130 ans libre à
ibrahima mbaye et olivier jean reste ça
se passe super bien et depuis d'ailleurs
pour nos résultats pour l'équipe une
alors départ catastrophique par exemple
on perd contre les 2 2 qui descendent et
en termine troisième vous finissez 3-0
fini troisième et pareil pour la 2 qui a
très mal commencé et qui finit également
3e du championnat est bon vous arrivez à
la transition ce qui est bien moi vous
arrivé troisième le l'équipe de aussi ça
fait des années que vous avez pas
dernier vous êtes dans l'oil toujours
dans les cinq premiers la montée alors
pour moi qui suit on va pas te dire go
pour toi la montée c'est pourquoi alors
bon on l'espère pour l'année prochaine
alors pourquoi parce que bon le système
est mis en place on a franchement on
s'est beaucoup améliorée dans le jeu la
qualité du jeu proposé et est très
satisfaisante
ce niveau de jeu on espère le garder
pour l'année prochaine on a déjà acquis
ce niveau donc on va essayer de le
préserver pour l'année prochaine et on a
aussi la volonté de de promouvoir nos
jeunes en réalité on a très peu fait
appel à des joueurs extérieurs
l'alliance est toujours wee cc juillet
et hop voilà ces légumes pour toi et je
crois que c'est la meilleure des
solutions
on s'en aperçoit année après année tant
au niveau des éducateurs qu'au niveau
des joueurs donc est joueuse et vous
allez aller les chercher où à versailles
non pas du tout avant la rencontre est
retransmise en clair on vient de nous
les prendre chez nous oui bah ça c'est
pour tout à fait vrai ça arrive ça
arrive
ça arrive assez fréquemment mais que là
cette fois vous irez les chercher où on
va aller chercher parce que en réalité
on n'a pas cette démarche on n'est pas
des recruteurs mais vous avez on est des
formateurs et on axe tout sur la
formation de nos éducateurs et ensuite
que ceux ci puissent former le mieux
possible nos joueurs et nos objectifs
bien sûr si on a un de nos joueurs qui
est demandé par un grand club on a tout
intérêt à faire tout pour qu'il y aille
mais l'homme derrière il faut a bien su
envoûter et mais on a bon pour vous
donner un type d'exemple on était 625
l'année dernière
cette saison on et 730 oui l'année
prochaine l'année prochaine c'est quoi
le choix pour cette équipe c'est la
montée oui comme ça donc c'est sûr et
certain
ah bah on va viser la montée parce qu'il
ya un changement au niveau des des
catégories au niveau ligue et au niveau
district et l'année prochaine la montée
pour cette division ces deux clubs qui
montent donc jouable donc on va tout
faire pour faire en sorte que l'équipe
ne montrent quelles seront les équipes à
alors celle qu'on va rencontrer à bord
c'est toujours difficile de rencontrer
des équipes 2 c'est le cas de versailles
qui est comme vous le savez ans
dh et qui va nous proposer donc une
équipe de assez forte
quand on les rencontre début de
championnat c'est toujours très
difficile
j'imagine et donc c'est surtout à eux
qui vont nous poser problème je pense
l'année prochaine donc pour finir qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter basse
écrasé à écouter c'est que on vise
depuis quelques temps le niveau régional
on l'a avec nos u13 qui son ancrage
régional nos u15 maintenant il nous
reste plus que les 17 19 et seniors donc
voilà l'objectif c'est ça je laime
dernière question et si un jour est ce
que vous avez dans l'idée de créer cette
fameuse équipe sans continuer à all
stars exact alors ça c'est peut-être un
voeu pieux mais je crois que tant que la
collectivité locale la communauté
d'agglo ne fait pas en sorte de créer
une équipe fanion quant au niveau des
seniors qu'au niveau une équipe fanion
par exemple en u19 u17 d'accord oui que
le reste soit reste dans les clubs des
communes parce que c'est très difficile
de cerner ce sera difficile de le fermer
mais j'espère qu'un jour ça se fera à
widnes à ça ça serait de donner mais on
a de très bons rapports avec nos amis de
trappes montigny donc y'a pas de soucis
pour qu'un jour ça se passe qui sait on
croise les doigts car on vous entendu je
vous remercie vous restez avec nous la
19e édition du festival solidays sera
organisé du 23 au 25 juin
comme chaque année plus de 80 concerts
seront organisés sur l'hippodrome de
longchamp en partenariat avec la région
ile de france
objectif récolter des fonds pour lutter
contre le sida
parmi les parrains de l'événement on
retrouve un chanteur qu'on a bien connu
dans les années 90 mc solaar ah oui vous
connaissez ah bah oui eh ben vous savez
quand on l'a interviewé enchante cette
partie pourquoi vous êtes vous réengager
cette année pour le solidays
je me réengage pour les solidays parce
que c'est une très bonne association
être
bien depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années et j'ai considéré qu'une partie
de mon temps c'était de l'art répondre
chaque fois qu'ils ont besoin de moi
parce que c'est un groupe ii
de bénévoles et de professionnels qui
travaillent toute l'année à faire les
choses et que c'est une noble cause donc
chaque fois qu'on aura besoin
j'essaierai d'être là pour apporter pas
grand chose par rapport à tout nombre
d'heures qu'ils font dans l'année vous
êtes parent du solidays depuis 14 ans si
j'ai bien compris 14 ans comment
évaluez-vous le solide et ce depuis 14
ans comment at il évolué il a grossi
c'était c'était une utopie je crois pour
les organisateurs et luc barbe et
d'antoine de caunes et tout ça et puis
c'est un enfant qui grandit quoi qui est
maintenant majeur est donc dans la force
de l'âge il grandit pas tout seul parce
que plus il grandit plus ça peut
retourner aux diverses associations que
cette collecte de fonds
voilà c'est pour reverser donc je suis
très content qu'ils grandissent très
bien pour pour ces centaines
d'associations qui en bénéficient toute
l'année les directeurs annonce une
baisse peut-être pour cette année quelle
est votre réaction par rapport à ça ben
c'est me motive et faire connaître
faire connaître grâce à vous oui une
baisse de fréquentation cette année
c'est pas encore finie je crois qu'il
faut relever les défis parce que c'est
c'est ce sera toujours plus pour pour le
fond et donc pour pour les différents
bénéficiaires à les y venez voir il y a
des gens que vous aimez c'est quoi les
solidays c'est quoi le l'ambiance
solidays l'ambiance solidaire c'est une
ambiance rock hip hop familiale chanson
française décalée kitsch c'est de
l'information c'est comment on appelle
ça de l'émotion avec le patchwork des
noms c'est de la découverte avec
l'exposition sex in the city ce sont des
forums donc c'est pour l'intellect
c'est aussi une sortie en plein air
entre amis ou familial avec tout ce qui
a de bien se dire autant des jeux que
que
donc un pique nique c'est du camping
c'est énorme c'est beaucoup de choses
voilà c'est donc le plaisir de la vie un
moment réussi
je crois que vous êtes très proche
également des bénévoles chaque année
vous allez leur rendre visite ça sera le
cas cette année à nouveau ben je ne sais
pas mais oui à priori je vais discuter
avec avec certains à prendre des chemins
de vie comment êtes vous arrivé là c'est
c'est important de moi j'ai jamais été
comment on appelle ça un associatif août
au japon j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
mais jamais sauté le pas donc je suis
toujours très fier de voir comment les
gens ils sautent le pas pour pour une
cause merci beaucoup même si cela merci
c'est la fin de cette suite les invités
merci de nous avoir suivis et surtout
bonne soirée
[Musique]